Tenemos la ecuación -5x + 4y = 20, y nos piden
encontrar las intersecciones de esta ecuación,
entonces tenemos que encontrar las intersecciones
y luego usarlas para graficar esta recta en
el plano coordenado, así que también nos piden
graficar la recta. Cada vez que alguien habla de
intersecciones se refiere a dónde intersecas los
ejes X y Y o se cruzan los ejes X y Y. Permíteme
etiquetar los ejes aquí: este es el eje X y este
es el eje Y, y cuando interseco el eje X o la
ordenada al origen, ¿qué está pasando?, ¿cuál
es mi valor y cuando estoy en el eje X? Bueno,
el valor de y es 0, porque no estoy por encima ni
por debajo del eje X. Permíteme escribir esto: la
intersección con la ordenada de origen es cuando
y = 0, y luego, usando el mismo argumento, ¿cuál
es la intersección con el eje Y o la abscisa al
origen? Bueno, si estoy en algún lugar a lo largo
del eje Y, ¿cuál es mi valor x? Pues como no estoy
ni a la derecha ni a la izquierda del eje el valor
x tiene que ser 0, por lo que la intersección
con el eje Y ocurre cuando x = 0. Entonces,
para encontrar las intersecciones establezcamos
y = 0 en esta ecuación y resolvamos x,
y luego establezcamos que x = 0 y resolvamos para
y. Entonces, cuando y = 0, ¿en qué se convierte
esta ecuación? Lo haré en anaranjado, queda 5x
negativo + 4y. Bueno, estamos diciendo que y es 0,
entonces 4 • 0 = 20, 4 • 0 es sólo 0, así que
podemos no escribir eso. Voy a reescribirlo:
-5x = 20. Podemos dividir ambos lados de esta
ecuación entre -5, el -5 se cancela, ese era el
punto detrás de dividir entre -5, y obtenemos x
= 20 / -5, es 4 negativo. Entonces, cuando y = 0,
vimos que x = -4; o si queremos graficar este
punto siempre colocamos la coordenada x primero,
por lo que sería el punto 4 negativo coma
0. Vamos a graficarlo: contamos 1, 2, 3, 4,
aquí es 4 negativo, y luego el valor de y es sólo
0, por lo que ponemos el punto justo allí, esa es
la intersección con el eje X u ordenada al
origen. cuando y es 0 x = -4. Observa que
estamos intersecando el eje X. Ahora hagamos
exactamente lo mismo para la intersección con
el eje Y o la abscisa al origen. Establezcamos x
= 0, tenemos -5 • 0 + 4y = 20. Bueno, cualquier
cosa multiplicada por 0 es 0, así que podemos
dejar eso fuera de la ecuación. Y recuerda:
aquí establecimos x = 0, estamos haciendo la
intersección con el eje Y, la abscisa al origen.
Entonces esto se simplifica como 4y = 20. Podemos
dividir ambos lados de esta ecuación entre 4 para
deshacernos de este 4 y obtenemos que y = 20
/ 4 que es 5. Entonces, cuando x = 0, y = 5,
por lo que el punto 0,5 está en la gráfica de esta
recta. Entonces, 0,5, x es 0, y es 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
justo allí. Y observa que cuando x es 0 estamos
justo en el eje Y, esta es nuestra abscisa al
origen justo allí. Y recuerda que para graficar
cualquier recta sólo necesitas dos puntos,
así que sólo tenemos que conectar los puntos y
aquí tenemos nuestra recta. Voy a conectar los
puntos haciendo mi mejor esfuerzo para
dibujar una recta lo más recta posible,
y esta es la gráfica de la ecuación usando
la ordenada al origen y la abscisa al origen.